dans le monde des nouvelles technologies
il est rare de voir des positions
dominantes demeurer aux mains des mêmes
acteurs pendant longtemps cette fois ci
c'est le géant youtube qui vient tout
juste de fêter ses 10 ans qui est menacé
par l'arrivée de facebook dans ce qui en
fait son essence même c'est à dire le
partage de vidéos matthieu dugal bonsoir
alors de quoi est-ce qu'il est question
au juste la concurrence en commençant il
faut rappeler ces lignes que ce qui est
vraiment ce qui marche actuellement la
sainte trinité de la popularité sur
internet c'est le partage de photos et
de vidéos sur des appareils mobiles ça
c'est l'eldorado pourquoi parce que ça
génère beaucoup d'interactions une
publication sur instagram par exemple
ces sites de partage de photos génère de
10 à 15 fois plus d'interaction que sur
facebook de 20 à 25 fois plus que sur
twitter c'est les annonceurs adore ce
alors par une des forces en présence
commençons par youtube dix ans un
milliard d'utilisateurs 4 milliards de
revenus publicitaires c'est le premier
site de partage de musique dans le monde
et c'est aussi surtout culturellement le
star system des jeunes générations par
exemple quand on regarde les quatre
contes les plus suivies sur youtube on
se rend compte que par exemple le
premier compte le plus suivi c'est pas
des stars d'hollywood c'est piot dubaï
un suédois qui fait de la chronique de
jeux vidéo 36 millions de fans youtube
spotlight donc les meilleurs moments du
youtube en deuxième position mais après
on a un comédien chilien aulas herman 22
millions de fans et des duos comiques
aux états unis plus de 20 millions de
fans donc c'est près de 80 millions de
fans que draine trois jeunes hommes de
25 à 30 ans c'est énorme bond et du côté
de facebook facebook mais facebook veut
devenir un site de partage de vidéos et
contrairement à ce qu'ont dit les jeunes
sont encore sur facebook les 18-24 plus
de 4 18 24 ans plus de 90% sont encore
là et on annoncée récemment du côté de
facebook on allait permettre par exemple
on aura fini le lecteur vidéo de
facebook on va leur permettre de publier
sur d'autres sites à partir de facebook
on va aussi changer l'algorithme de
facebook pour que les vidéos est une
meilleure place donc si vous créez une
vidéo directement sur facebook elle va
paraître très haut dans le fil de
nouvelles et par exemple il ya des sites
d'information comme vox médias récemment
qui a obtenu une entrevue avec barack
obama vox qui est un des uns des
conglomérats
yat-il qui le vend le plus en poupe ils
ont pas mis le clip sur youtube ils ont
mis le clic directement sur facebook
parce que facebook faut pas oublier ils
ont le réseau social de google toujours
voulu avoir parce que google plus assez
de concurrencer facebook qu'ils ont
jamais réussi et la facebook a quand
même un certain avantage parce que ils
ont le réseau et ils peuvent décider des
termes selon lesquelles c'est qu'il
pleut vont êtres vont être diffusés et
on a aussi appris récemment que youtube
hier conclu une entente avec dreamworks
avec le studio à sommes restés vides
dreamworks pour produire de la deûle
attelly de haute qualité va faire un peu
comme netflix donc c'est une guerre très
très grosse qui quitte en train de se
préparer entre ces deux géants là qu'est
ce que ça veut dire est ce que ça va
donner est-ce qu'on va se retrouver
qu'un fils double d'ici 2 3 a battu qu'à
l'avenir l'avenir de le dire en tout cas
en 10 ans il s'en est passé des choses
non - ouais merci beaucoup monsieur
plaisir